pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le nouvel an le président de gaulle
a reçu par la voix d'une once
pontificale les voeux du corps
diplomatique échange de souhaits
officielle qui se fondait dans l'écho
des paroles que préludant aux tâches et
aux difficultés de la nouvelle année le
chef de l'état adressé aux français pour
l'algérie nous voulons que 1961 soit
l'année de la paix rétablie
afin que les populations puissent
décider librement de leur destin et pour
que naisse l'algérie algérienne
françaises français je vous le demande
donnée aux projets qui vous est soumis
une approbation immense car s'il devait
arriver par malheur que la réponse du
pays fut ou négative ou 1 10 6 en raison
d'une faible majorité ou marqué par
beaucoup d'abstention quelles
conséquences résultera de cette
impuissance et de sept divisions et à
moi même
vous le savez bien quel coût serait
ainsi porté ma pêchant de poursuivre ma
tâche
françaises français aujourd'hui
tous ensemble nous offrons nos voeux à
la france le 8 janvier
nous lui offrirons le oui franc et
massif de notre espoir est de notre foi
cette plaque dévoilée à l'ancienne
entrée de leur collège combien d'élèves
la côtoieront il sans y porter attention
pourtant elle rappelle que dans l'ombre
du tout jeune panthéon sainte barbe
vient d'avoir 500 ans un demi millénaire
c'est dire que quelques générations ont
précédé ici les fringants barbistes de
1961 l'acte de fondation date en effet
de 1460 cette année là le plus vieux
collège de paris ouvrait ses portes sur
la montagne sainte geneviève
alors que la république appelait encore
la rue aux chiens le temps passe un mail
à tours où habite à calvin existe
toujours
le décor passa du 18e ou 19e sans trop
de transformation ils connurent ses
cours ce réfectoire ce dortoir
certains élèves devenus célèbres comme
charles péguy qui fut poète et jérôme
tarot qui fut académisme ils connurent
t-il jaurès bonne élève au bilan
élogieux
et paul deschanel cancre sans espoir que
sa lettre de renvoi n'empêcha pas de
devenir président de la république
l'histoire a passé cinq cents ans se
sont donc inscrits aux livres de comptes
que le collège conserve les révolution
de 1830 puis de 48 ne fut remarqué que
par des consignes et des punitions en
1961 les barbistes peuvent rêver à la
gloire de certains de leurs anciens
aussi différents qu'ignace de loyola
jean calvin saint françois xavier
les frères montgolfier gustave eiffel
et l'on peut imaginer que parmi ces
jeunes visages il y aura peut-être un
créateur d'ordre 1ere ziar un inventeur
un constructeur de génie et quoi encore
plus de trains des gares déserte plus de
postes les sacs postaux en attente
plus debout et les ordures envahissant
les rues c'est le spectacle qu'offre
toute la belgique en ce début d'année
tout au plus à bruxelles d'une fraction
de postiers at elle tenté de continuer
le travail sous la protection de la
force publique
le grand meeting ont acclamé la grève
générale dirigée contre le gouvernement
et skins promoteurs de mesures
d'austérité connu sous le nom de loi
unique dont les grévistes ont fait loi
inique anvers comme toutes les grandes
villes a suivi bruxelles des
manifestations se sont déroulées qui
disait un flamand ce que les autres
disent est en français
et les jours passant la grève après pied
partout les manifestations se sont
aggravées on a vu dans les rues de la
capitale dix mille manifestants défilent
et derrière leur second combatif et
transformer parfois leur marche en
désordre
la 11e journée de cette grève illimitée
la première depuis 10 ans a même vu le
sang coulait des blessés un mort et pour
le reste les vestiges habituel des
émeutes
comment se résoudre à la crise dont la
grève n'est que le décor fiévreux toute
l'économie belge est stoppée mines
déserte port vide
les grévistes tiendront-ils le
gouvernement cédera-t-il le roi de
retour ramènera t-il le calme
on attend
[Musique]
c'est une fin d'année dramatique qu'a
connu l'équipage du pétrolier américain
pas une ride coupée en deux par la
tempête dans l'atlantique au large du
cap a trace alors que l'avant avec ou
les 29 hommes avaient trouvé refuge sur
la partie arrière rester à flot les
hélicoptères du porte-avions valley
forge et puis les évacuer à l'exception
du chef mécanicien qui tend à rester à
bord l'ultime gardien de départ et qui
devaient rentrer avec elle à bon port
pour eux c'était au drame une fin
heureuse
mais cet homme manquait les officiers
rester sur l'inventaire du corps et
biens
odeur de l'oubangui le plus importants
affluents du congo bangui a terminé
l'année 1960 dans un calme qui
n'excluait pas la liesse
le chef de l'état monsieur david dacko
qui avait à ses côtés monsieur louis
jacquinot ministre d'état français à
président et diverses cérémonies
la nouvelle république centrafricaine ça
devrait en effet les fêtes de son
indépendance proclamée le trésor depuis
cette date l'ancien oubangui chari est
en effet devenu un état souverain de 617
mille kilomètres carrés
c'est à dire plus grand que la france et
qui compte un million huit cent mille
habitants
andy la capitale qui a vu se dérouler
une semaine de réjouissances peut être
considéré comme le symbole de l'avenir
modeste poste voici cinquante ans c'est
aujourd'hui une cité de près de 100000
habitants jeunesse qui promet voici
reggab reggane autrement dit une ville
ou plutôt un centre ultramoderne
construit au coeur du désert à 15 100 km
au sud de rang aux portes du tanezrouft
et y trouve sa justification dans la
série d'expériences nucléaire dans la
troisième vient d'avoir lieu un nombre
respectable de kilomètres séparent
reggane du lieu de l'explosion
là depuis plusieurs jours l'engin était
prêt au sommet de sa tour dans la tempe
des vents favorables alentours chakar
n'avait disposé du matériel témoins le
génie ces ponts la cavalerie ses chars
et leurs servants fictif l'armée de
l'air ces avions les uns protégée par un
mur de béton les autres sans protection
et même une fusée
l'infanterie elle avait disposé des
mannequins bien alignées comme il se
doit ou dans la position du tireur
couché des cages étaient réservées à des
animaux cobayes il est maintenant 7h30
le général kir et actionne un bouton
et dans la nuit seul l'oeil de la caméra
est fixe et en face l'éclairer bluey
sens de la troisième banque française
il s'agissait cette fois d'un engin de
faible puissance quelques kilotonnes
précise le communiqué des armées un
nouveau pas vers la miniaturisation de
la bombe à trets lutte nécessaire à la
bande h premier autorisés à s'approcher
de la zone interdite
les hélicoptères porteurs d'eau compteur
geiger est chargée de vérifier le danger
de radioactivité après eux les équipes
d'observation pouvaient à leur tour
reprendre le chemin du point d'explosion
les divers témoins placées autour du
point zéro et dont on a vu l'état l'âge
avait en effet des renseignements à
fournir sur les effets immédiats des
radiations et sur leur persistance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
râteau
les animaux quant à eux était attendu au
bourget lapin tortue cobayes ra
maintenant on va étudier les effets de
la bombe numéro 3 et regan rentrée pour
un temps dans le silence
[Musique]